hey guys it's Jonah here most of us
think that in order to burn calories it
means running or jumping around but
that's not always the case you can't fit
in a high-intensity workout which is
low-impact but you will be absolutely
drenched in sweat and your heart rate
will be pumping so today's workout is a
low impact cardio which is a public
friendly and you won't be needing
anyways so get your body warmed up and
let's do it this workout will work on
your entire body so let's start with the
first workout which is high any much
okay I just want you to March and bring
your knees as high as possible all right
we're going to start easy and treat this
as part of your warm up as well good
so each workout would be for 40 seconds
long with 10 seconds to rest in between
okay short rest to really keep your
heart rate pumping good keep going if
you want to you can add a knee pull up
and pull good so stretch up reach up and
bring your knees up and fills your
co-working at the same time good so
March and keep marching and remember
always pace your breathing keep reaching
and pull very good so pull crunching
crunching and crunch good keep going
last two more seconds and rest second
workout will be squat with kicks so
squat forward okay kick forward squat
and kick to the side and squat and kick
to the back ready let's go squat push
and squat and kick squat to the back and
now the other side squat kick forward
squat to the side squat and back good so
you're working on your legs
from every angle very good remember as
you squat go low go deep good to the
side and to the back let's go squat
front sight
squeeze your outer thighs good squeeze
your glutes and one more forward squeeze
your outer thighs squeeze your glutes
March it out now let's do some reverse
lunges with touch down okay so step
forward and what I want you to do is
bring one leg back and touch down bring
your knees as low as you can
good so the goal is to keep your body as
low as you can and the reason why we
want to touch the ground is to make sure
that you're going low enough good so
both knees bent and 90 degrees very good
so keep going touch and change well push
with your legs push up with your heels
feel your glutes and bring your body
down touch down
don't hunch forward keep your chest up
and test very good keep going bring it
back one more and on the other side and
rest it out right side lunges with a
twist so start on your right okay so
step and bring it up with a twist ready
let's go step and twist stab feel the
right glutes through the right thighs
and also the outer and inner thigh good
and twist feel your oblique muscles very
good twist good land gently okay this is
supposed to be a public rally so you do
not want your neighbors to hear you good
keep going keep twisting both arms up
very good
elbow to knee elbow to knee twist go
deeper lunch lower very good now on the
other side okay so left leg and twist
ready let's go
laughs Lake and threes good so now you
should be working on your left glutes
and on your right inner thighs
very good go low and twist bring it up
find your balance
look straight ahead to find your balance
whoa keep going twist down and up
very good to ease as much as you can
reach your knee to your elbow if you
can't reach it it's okay okay try your
very best keep going and breathe in and
breathe out good nice that wider go
lower one last one and sweep right load
squat walk okay so I wanted to start in
the middle okay our weight to get into a
low squat and just walk forward and back
that's it so the intensity will be
coming from you maintaining this low
position it's like a little crab walk
all right do not come up okay you want
to feel the intensity on your muscles
here stay low forward and back forward
and back right let's lead with your
right leg good right leg forward and
right leg back stay you know all right I
can feel you keep going do not stop
right now
whew last five more seconds come on push
it feel your thighs burning that's what
we want
oh and shake it out now stop right at
the end of your mat we want to get into
an inchworm
with push up okay so at the end slowly
inch forward keep your hamstrings and
your leg straight give me a nice push up
and inch back okay by keeping your legs
straight you will really feel on your
hamstrings very good forward push up
nice and deep and back if you can't do
the full pushup
that is okay start on your knees nice
deep push up bring your chest
as low to the ground as possible squeeze
your gluts
and let's go again down and go back
stand straight
open up your chest and go down and up
very good
all right back off on the ground okay
this will really work on your course
stop right at the end of the mat go
forward okay four times bring your elbow
close to your knee and reverse okay
so keeping your back flat all the time
do not pipe okay keep your low look
forward feel your legs working and your
core muscles engaged and go back very
good
so all the way forward and all the way
back keep going
this is called back row okay keep going
back keep your legs pointed forward your
knees pointed forward and last one go
back and one final workout plank is done
so let's get down to the floor let's
start in a simple plank position basic
plank all right we want to keep our body
straight and push up and back down very
good push up and dump so alternate
between arms okay right down left up
left down right up
very good keeping your body flat and
with minimal hip movement up and down
this is your final workout let's go
and you will get it's 30 seconds rest
right after this and up give me five
more here five more seconds
let's go down up down and restaurant
very very well done I told you you will
be sweaty so take this 20 seconds left
to keep yourself hydrated what we'll
start off and we want to do step number
two
[Music]
set number two I want you to push
yourself and give me your best effort so
let's start with exercise number one
which is a high knee with a pool down
okay let's go
high knee and pull it down good reach up
as high as you can and crunch and bring
your knees up good every time you reach
up you will be working on your back
muscles and also your core muscles okay
keep going keep pulling and keep
yourself light on your toes
very good so March and pull when it
comes to exercising it's really up to
you how hard you want to be pushing
yourself because it's such a short
workout I want you to really give me
your best shot
very good keep going few more give me
two more on each side last one more and
rest it out next workout squats with
kicks okay
so squat forward with a front kick side
and it's a back hit okay open up a chest
ready
let's go squat forward front kick work
on your outer glutes work on your glutes
very good at the other side forward
right take it like you mean it down kick
back very good let's go forward and to
your side down and to the back very good
show me those kicks kick to the side
down into the back alright let's go
we're not stopping right now show me
those high kicks you've got this to the
back and on the other side hi nice side
pull it back and the last one and just
shake it out reverse lunge with a
touchdown
so step forward okay - with your map we
want to reverse lunge and touch down
okay keep your chest open let's go step
and alternate side good so switch and
switch very good keep going
tap down and tap down okay do not hunch
your back
it is about bending your knees and
bringing yourself low very good keep
your knees bent
and keep them at a 90-degree angle keep
going keep tapping very good feel your
glute muscles working well you guys
upload do not stop right now do not come
up stay low stay focused I don't wait to
give me a few more ok last two more last
one more the other side restaurant very
good sight lunge with a twist ok let's
work on our right side first so step on
one side of your mat let's go twist and
bring it up good so sludge and up lunch
to the side and out good so reach your
elbows to your knees very good twist
feel your obliques working keep both
arms up by your face ok find your
balance by looking straight ahead twist
step down gently twist step down
do you inner thighs you're right in
advice keep going you have 10 seconds
left ok good
keep your right leg straight and twist
your obliques very good few more down up
down and up
very good now keep your left leg
straight we want to work on the left
inner thighs ok so ready let's step
there and twist on the other side good
let's go step and twist step and twist
okay she's gonna face you step and twist
very good keep going step and twist feel
your obliques feel your right cheek
muscles working and feel your left inner
thighs very good keep going keep
twisting oh my god I am sweaty and I
hope you're sweaty as well very good
well keep yourself light on your toes
look forward find that balance find that
strength within you and breathe in and
breathe out last one more twist and
restaurants next workout which is my
favorite and also hates it workout low
squat walk okay so let's start facing
forward let's get into a low squat and
let's
forward with your left first okay so
keep her chest open and just take small
steps forward with your left leg and
your right good keep going keep your
butt low chest open very good nice
you're doing a good job feel your legs
on fire
keep going and now let's lead with your
right leg come up right now this is your
final set I went into hanging there okay
push your muscles that's how you will
grow your muscles and burn lots of
calories keep going right leg back one
more oh my gosh shake it out
inchworm to push up okay so step right
at the end of your mat keep your leg
straight working your hamstrings let's
go inch forward down push up and inch
back okay as much as you can keep your
legs straight to really stretch on your
hamstrings down and up go back when you
stand up squeeze your gluts good it's
all about working on the entire body
very good nice deep push-ups Oh keep
going see your sweat dripping on the mat
that is your effort nobody else's but
your acid last one and come back up huh
back row okay last two exercises start
whoo right at the end of your mat okay
so stay low back flat bring your knee to
your elbow and reverse okay
so about four to six steps forward and
four to six six steps back
very good go back
keep going and always remember keeping
your back flat keep your knees almost
close to the ground very very good
so this workout it's just a really good
way tricep muscles keep going back
breathe
my entire mass is drenched now who say
you need to jump around in order to
sweat and burn calories now let's go
down ok find a workout guys find a
workout sprang up down ok do it like you
mean it
right regular planks ready let's go up
down up and down remember to alternate
your arms right and now let's go left
down whoa my hundred is on fire
left and up I am not stopping because I
only have 20 seconds left so I'm gonna
push myself and give my effort my very
best effort because I know right after
this I'm getting a break well-deserved
break let's go kid going five more
seconds down up down and then rest it
out get into a house house and bring
your heart rate back down okay
I thought guys every time I end my
workout I've always drenched in sweat
okay
look at my sweat this is a low impact
cardio workout no jumping needed no
rates needed just your body your
strength and your focus okay so do this
workout be consistent incorporate this
workout into your routine at least three
to four times weekly on alternate days
and trust me you will start to lean up
you will start to burn fat and you will
feel so good about yourself so be sure
to like this video share this workout
get your friends to join you and let me
know how you get on in the comments
below because I want to be following
your fitness progress okay ah wipe your
sweat and you can start your beautiful
day don't forget to also subscribe to my
youtube channel for a lot more workout
videos workout challenges and hit the
notification button so that you will get
notified every time I upload a new
workout video and also recipes all the
best